and the whole like fighter pay
thing um if you look at the UFC as a
business like it it the way they do it
makes perfect sense it does I mean yeah
in any business you know any business
you got to start in the mail room and
then work your way up right right or you
started in the mail room somewhere else
and then you end up working your way up
like it's life is a meritocracy you get
what you you get what you put in
whatever your Merit is you will then get
compensated more and more and more and
it's tough because it's not if you look
at fighter pay compared to other
organizations the fighter pay isn't off
as a matter of fact there's only one way
to get truly truly rich and financially
wealthy in the sport and that's through
the UFC however all you know a lot of
the other guys who are working their way
up you know they start out off at a low
salary just like everybody starts off at
a low salary in a certain business in a
certain sector and then as meritocracies
would have it the more you bring to the
table the more you get paid right but it
the argument is tough because all people
say is well the UFC is making this much
so therefore they should be sharing that
with the fighters the employees the
independent contractors whatever but if
you look at other organizations that's
just because they're not as profitable
it's just because they're not as good of
a product they don't they don't reinvest
into the sport they don't reinvest into
building the entire sport so you're
saying like Bellator might pay a larger
percentage of their revenue to the
fighters but there's just less Revenue
tons of less Revenue there's almost no
there's almost no revenue and there's no
almost no reinvestment so I was the
biggest name in Bellator for the last
five years I was there my last five
fights I had a camera on me one time I
came to the UFC in the first six months
at they were flying out to my house to
do this little this little piece and
then follow me in the the UFC countdown
and then getting ready for this and get
I me they are they reinvest hundreds of
millions of dollars back into into the
UFC every year which is really into the
sport of mixed martial arts because they
have quarterbacked and championed the
entire sport to raise the elevation and
that Rising tide has raised All Ships
pfl Bellator one Championship everyone
else yeah they they on the Patrick Bet
David podcast they pulled up the p&l
statement for UFC and they ran if you
look at the p&l statement payroll for
the UFC accounted for like 44% of the
expenses the rest of it with marketing
and all the reinvestment to do to grow
the business you know so what you're
saying is like on Bellator the payroll
might be 70% of the revenue that they
you know the expenses that they bring in
but zero marketing zero I mean not zero
I'm not going to say zero but and that's
what I would say too because people are
talking about pfl and Bellator the the
now the new conglomerate and I'm say
well there's only one thing that they
need to do in order to continue to gain
this profile and that's spend more money
on marketing and they're doing a good
job they got Francis zanu they got Jake
Paul and there's these other guys who
can be a a mouthpiece and be a be a a
big platform type of person to be able
to help grow the entire the entire brand
but I uh hit up I hit up Ariel helwani
after the enanu fight because he um I
saw a tweet that he put out and it was
uh you know he was defending the
pay-per-view numbers that that Inu Fury
fight did it's like everyone said it was
only this many you know like and and he
says yeah well that you're not counting
uh you know International pay-per-views
and and you know and and everywhere and
and I just hit up arel I said why are
you even defending the uh the
pay-per-views on that like they're
besides the point because you know even
if we assume that it was a catastrophic
failure and nobody saw
it doesn't change the fact that
everybody heard about the fact that in
ganu shocked the world and now everybody
is ready to mark their calendars to hand
over their money to watching ganu box
again yeah like so doesn't even matter
like that his dues are paid and it
doesn't matter what that fight did
business-wise because his next fight is
the whole bag true yeah so so the so
what you're saying is the the general
storyline was hey look look at how big
this fight was supposed to be and it
didn't do as as good of numbers as we
thought and there is some truth to that
too I mean everybody you know pfl has
tried to do it Bellator they did it you
know and they sold like 100,000
pay-per-views or less you know it's like
the UFC they just put on this show and
they sell pay-per-view and they do it
because they because everyone knows
about it man it was it was the most
frustrating thing for me to to know
training alongside all these UFC guys
and I put in more work lived a better
Championship lifestyle than they did
beating them in the in the practice room
I was the guy I was living that that
champion lifestyle yet my fight would be
happening and there would be a UFC Fight
Night that same weekend and they would
send all the first string reporters to
there we'd get the second string
reporters if we got any it just seemed
like such a smaller deal than even a
mediocre UFC card and that's the brand
that they have built so maybe I'm a
brown noser and a bootlicker and all
that stuff that everyone you know calls
me but it's like I just understand the
business and I've been around the
business and I have the luxury of
knowing what it's like to be outside of
the UFC right and then coming into the
UFC and then watching it just go do you
like shopping on Amazon I do and good
news is sto's butt wipes for your
butthole are available on Amazon and if
you want a real bundle of a deal you can
get steo hot sauce for your butthole
plus sto's butthole destroyer and sto's
butt wipes for your butthole it's the
butthole bundle available on Amazon
right
now
yeah dude